les coups de feu retentissaient
alors que des frères se battaient
alors que les frères se battent dans un
pays divisé sur son avenir
un pays relativement jeune qui a eu son
indépendance il y a moins d'un siècle et
maintenant brisé en souffrance divisée
alors comment trouver le moyen de faire
la paix et de se réunir
pour faire un avenir meilleur en tant
que pays en tant que peuple uni
cette histoire n'est que trop familière
pour de nombreux pays qui ont été
confrontés par des conflits
par des difficultés économiques et par
des crises sociales
en fait cette histoire est celle de mon
pays les États-Unis qui grâce à ces
institutions démocratiques à trouver
l'adaptabilité et la résilience
nécessaire pour faire face
en effet les États-Unis autrefois
étaient en guerre contre eux-mêmes
divisé sur la question du droit de
posséder une personne
l'esclavagisme
la traite des esclaves qui a déchiré des
familles ici en Afrique
a vu les familles se diviser de l'autre
côté de l'Atlantique
pourtant au lieu de sortir de la guerre
meurtrie les États-Unis sont entre elles
dans une nouvelle ère de croissance et
de développement ou la valeur d'une
personne n'était pas n'était pas
fonction de ses origines mais plutôt
fonction de ce qu'elle voulait devenir
en fait oui on est entré dans une
nouvelle ère de croissance et et voilà
la valeur d'une personne n'était pas
fonction de ce que ce qu'elle ses
origines mais de ce qu'elle voulait
devenir
notre très tôt dans notre histoire nous
avons appris une leçon précieuse la
résilience de la démocratie
c'est donc de cela dont je veux vous
parler aujourd'hui comment les
démocraties rebondissent et comment ici
en Guinée nous pouvons rebondir ensemble
tout d'abord il faut il faut savoir ce
que c'est exactement la démocratie
selon les Red Diamonds spécialiste de la
démocratie à l'université de Stanford
c'est un type de gouvernance comportant
4 éléments clés
premièrement un système permettant de
choisir et de remplacer le gouvernement
un gouvernement par des élections libres
équitables
deuxièmement la participation active des
citoyens à la vie civique et politique
troisièmement la protection des droits
de l'âme pour tous
et enfin
un état de droit qui s'applique de
manière égale à tous les citoyens
mais la démocratie n'est pas une
condition statique sinon un processus
100 ans après notre guerre civile un
descendant d'esclaves a écrit
l'arc de l'univers moral est long mais
il se courbe vers la justice
en effet docteur Martin Luther King est
rapidement devenu un leader des droits
civils
apprécié non seulement dans mon pays
mais dans le monde entier
docteur Luther King croyait au pouvoir
de la démocratie de créer un avenir
meilleur et plus égalitaire
il s'est battu pour que les Américains
de couleur et les mêmes droits
vous savez les cicatrices de notre
guerre civile aux Etats-Unis n'ont
jamais été complètement guéri
bien que nous ayons éradiqué
l'esclavagisme aux États-Unis nous
l'avions remplacé par des systèmes de
discrimination raciale contraire à nos
idéaux démocratiques
au lieu de recourir à la violence
docteur Luther King a utilisé ces mêmes
fondamentaux de la démocratie pour
provoquer le changement
en 1964 le Congrès américain a adopté la
loi sur les droits civils
garantissant la l'égalité de traitement
de toutes les personnes
indépendamment de leur couleur de leur
race de leur religion de leur sexe ou de
leur origine nationale
aujourd'hui encore les Américains
tentent de poursuivre le rêve de docteur
Luther King
de restant cas de traitement policiers
de personnes de couleur aux États-Unis
ont mis en évidence le travail qui reste
à faire
certes les États-Unis ont leur propre
défaut
mais la démocratie permet de rebondir
la question de savoir comment comment
gouverner c'est toujours posé
le philosophe grec Aristote affirmait
que la démocratie est le meilleur d'un
mauvais lot de système politique
selon lui la démocratie offre la
possibilité de combiner les vertus du
plus grand nombre
et en effet si on prend l'exemple de
Jules César et Rome ou Soundiata Keita
et l'Empire malien les intérêts d'une
seule personne ont provoqué
l'effondrement de leur empire
d'un autre côté les démocraties ont
démontré leur capacité à rebondir
en fait les démocraties ont toujours
bon j'ai déjà parlé des États-Unis
et de la manière dont nous avons revendu
par le passé
examinons donc un exemple un peu plus
proche de chez nous
le Ghana
ce que la France peut représenter pour
la Guinée il en est de même pour le
Royaume-Uni et le Ghana
en 1957
le en 1957 le Ghana est devenu la
Première nation de l'Afrique
subsaharienne a déclaré la fin de la
domination coloniale britannique
un an plus tard comme vous le savez la
Guinée est devenue la première à mettre
fin à la domination coloniale française
comme la Guinée le Ghana a connu une
série de coup d'état et de dirigeants
autoritaires dans les décennies qui ont
suivi l'indépendance
en 1992 les choses ont commencé à
changer
suite au référendum constitutionnel de
1992 au Ghana
le Ghana a tenu sa première élection
démocratique ce qui a entraîné un
développement social et économique
constant
depuis 1992 le pays B de Ghana est passé
de 6 milliards de dollars jusqu'à 70 17
milliards de dollars
l'espérance de vie a augmenté de six ans
la mortalité infantile indicateur commun
du développement et de l'accès aux
services publics à chuté de 75% jusqu'à
35% aujourd'hui
récemment le Ghana et la démocratie de
du Ghana a été challenge
lors des élections de 2012 l'ancien
ministre des Affaires étrangères nana
akufo ado a perdu sa deuxième
candidature à la présidence face à John
Mahama
il a contesté les résultats et l'affaire
est allée jusqu'à la Cour suprême qui
les a confirmé
as-tu accepté cette décision
déclarant à l'époque nous respectons et
nous croyons en la Cour suprême et nous
accepterons tout Verdi qu'elle rendra
ce respect pour les institutions
démocratiques a eu un impact profond sur
la démocratie ghanéenne et à créer aussi
un précédent pour les autres démocraties
africaines
dans les années qui ont suivi
cette élection les législateurs Ghanéens
ont renforcé leur système électoral le
même système qu'au fond ado a utilisé
pour se présenter une nouvelle fois à la
présidence
cette fois il a gagné il est aujourd'hui
le 5e président du Ghana
alors que retenir de l'exemple ghanéen
c'est un peuple qui s'est mis en tête de
forger sa propre voix
du colonialisme à la démocratie en
passant par l'autoritarisme
tout n'est pas encore parfait n'importe
quel ghanéen ici présent vous le direz
mais le Ghana a prouvé que si l'on
investit dans les institutions
démocratiques pour construire la
résilience le développement social et
économique suivra
voilà
tout au long de l'histoire si quoi que
ce soit aux États-Unis ou au Ghana nous
avons vu que la démocratie n'est pas
facile
chaque pays chaque communauté est
différent avec des cultures des
histoires des défis et des désirs
différents
ce qui a fonctionné dans un pays ne va
pas forcément fonctionner ailleurs
et en fait la démocratie fournit le
modèle mais la façon dont ce modèle est
mis en pratique dépend du peuple
qu'est-ce que cela signifie pour la
Guinée
aujourd'hui la Guinée se trouve à la
croisée des chemins
le pays a connu des défis
coup d'État
élections contestée autoritarisme
référendum constitutionnel
pourtant les Guinéens n'ont jamais
reculé de leur quête d'un pays meilleur
un pays plus plus libre et démocratique
qui fonctionne pour le peuple
vous savez que ce n'est pas une tâche
facile
même Aristote reconnaît la difficulté de
la tâche il affirme que réformer un
système politique et tout aussi
difficile que d'en créer un depuis le
début
donc je ne suis pas ici pour vous dire
que la démocratie est facile ni parfaite
je ne dis pas qu'il suffit d'organiser
des élections pour que la prospérité et
l'égalité suivent immédiatement non
cela prend du temps il faut de la
persévérance mais vous n'êtes pas seul
alors peut-être vous vous êtes demandé
pourquoi ce diplôme est américain est
ici aujourd'hui
la réponse est simple
parce que je parce que parce que nous
nous en souillions nous les États-Unis
nous avons été à votre place nous le
sommes toujours
confrontés à une tâche apparemment
insurmontable
se battre pour rebondir après chaque
défi
les États-Unis sont ici en Guinée depuis
l'indépendance
pour vous aider à relever ces défis
nous ne voulons pas vous imposer les
solutions mais simplement vous partagez
notre expérience de la démocratie
si les institutions démocratiques fortes
sont créées
si chaque personne est traitée de la
même manière par la loi
si les doigts de l'âme sont protégés et
si les gens participent à la vie civique
et politique
la démocratie fonctionnera pour vous
nous sommes dans la même équipe alors
rebondissons ensemble merci
[Applaudissements]